premiers pas sur la pelouse du stade
gaston berthe en présentation à la
presse benoît cauet et trance et
entraîneur de la berrichonne à son
palmarès de joueur une coupe de l'uefa
remportée avec l'inter milan
deux titres de champion de france avec
l'olympique de marseille une finale de
supercoupe d'europe avec le paris
saint-germain
son cv d'entraîneurs est moins fournie
seule une saison en national à lui s
concarneau le successeur de nicolas usaï
s'est engagé à châteauroux jusqu'à la
fin de saison avec en option une année
supplémentaire en cas de maintien
il ya un groupe d'hommes il ya des gens
ici qui ont encore des années construit
quelque chose je crois qu'il ya des
valeurs il ya des valeurs dans ce club
il ya des valeurs dans ce mot je pense
qu'il faut et c'est peut-être un peu
endormi en ce moment il faut le
réveiller quitter la place de lanterne
rouge se maintenir en ligue 2 c'est
l'objectif du club berrichon qui a
renouvelé tout son staff technique
en parallèle la direction négocie le
rachat du club par un investisseur
saoudien
la lettre d'intention a été signée les
parties sont d'accord sur
l'investissement des deux groupes sur le
club dont tout et tout est calé à ce
niveau là kayal processus logique qui se
fait pour aller sur un sur un acte de
vente qui devrait qui devrait intervenir
dans le courant du mois de janvier ou
fin du mois de janvier
une perspective qui suscite des
réactions contrastées côté supporters
c'est pour l'investisseur qui vient qui
va venir
créer un esprit d'équipé sont des
joueurs ça peut être que bénéfique aussi
si en plus il amène de l'argent
dumont qui regarde aussi le sens de
formation 20 benoît cauet fera ses
débuts d'entraîneur mardi prochain à
l'occasion d'un déplacement à troyes
pour le compte de la 18e journée de
ligue 2